[Music]
in Caveman Playboy news Oh
caveman playboy caveman playboy oh I
heard about this is that hey yep oh okay
let's tell the story submitted by you me
says hi JK fam hi yeah it's a pretty ass
[ __ ] name you mean - you mean me you
use that for rush hour that's not like a
Chris Tucker Jackie Chan conversation
well little girl I am you a Thai caveman
goes viral after bragging about seducing
dozens of women whoa hell yeah will you
just [ __ ] Muay Thai them to the face
and knock about okay you reminds me of
like those hippy hipster guys with
dreadlocks that live in like kind of
homeless but he's like super eccentric
and artist like and then he gets like
mad [ __ ] but agen caveman version yeah
do I hate those hippies that [ __ ]
lecture you about life yeah I mean like
have you met those type of dudes oh
thank god a lot of people you like like
it'll be like a friend of a friend
they're super into like hyper holistic
[ __ ] and then you'll be eating something
like you know what bro that's actually
not good for the alkaline levels in your
body it's like hey [ __ ] nobody [ __ ]
asked you shut the [ __ ] up I hate that
[ __ ] dude there's I mean I know people
like that but they're not so force force
like force for I hate that [ __ ] dude let
me eat my [ __ ] waffle [ __ ] don't
[ __ ] talk to me with my [ __ ]
waffle the help alright so let's do it
here he's 48 years good luck he's a time
man he's the self-proclaimed caveman
lucky he posts on his Facebook page has
page where people follow bad that cave
got Wi-Fi
who got DIRECTV in the first twenty
eighteen twenty eighteen caves [ __ ]
red 1848 I want to buy a 10 at 48 I want
to buy you out that right now you do
have a body like that right now bro they
look just like you shirtless you just
gotta get 10 what are you talking about
that's a trashy came okay like kill post
photos of like the western women that
he'll seduce hell yeah she look trashy
she look like she is face is weird
it's pasted something hasn't [ __ ] a
Thai woman in years because he looks
like a jacked Thai Snoop Dogg - oh my
god yes noob dog yes he's my soul stone
right there
playboy grows yes all these girls look
like they would travel to Thailand to
[ __ ] this yeah yeah they all they all
look like they want to [ __ ] unlock
their chakras and jeez this guy's
bragging about like like I [ __ ] all the
white girls and it's like ah but you
know they're not like like the cream of
the crop you know I mean like it's like
the same way that other people do this
all the girls look like they smell the
same yeah I look like they want to join
a call yeah the call type of white girls
I was in Thailand and oh my god this guy
unlocked by [ __ ] chocolates in his cave
oh are you sure you're fantasizing them
because they might be fantasizing you
buddy
yeah that's no different from like these
guys going to Thailand for sex tourism
it's the same [ __ ] I know yeah he's
loving it and he's saying like no women
had like he's never forced any of these
women they always go there and if he
would probably even say that like what
do you ever be like yeah I force all of
them me tell you just [ __ ] elbow just
[ __ ] look like they're having a good
time though police raided is Kate like
they went is Kate
and they were just making sure that
there wasn't anything suspicious or
illegal yeah he goes because that
happened after he posted this photo you
got he got raped
no don't he was saying something like I
woke up at 7:00 a.m. I meditated he's
like yeah and he took a photo of one of
his lovers I thought that was him no
this is a woman that big-ass PSA like a
size men's photo you got a ton of
backlash cuz you they were like bold she
even thought was I think that was him
that's him that's gotta be him it's all
dark too because that's a man woman to
you oh you know what you can see the
hair long hair that is a girl that looks
like a man and car go home that's him
that's a man's body he just literally
took a picture of him knocked out cuz he
[ __ ] so much
that's the cockiest picture I've ever
seen in my life himself it's either he
took a picture of himself or the girl
took a picture of him yeah I think the
girl took a picture here you were saying
like he was posting this photo and he
was talking about how he woke up
whatever he's like but someone's still
asleep that's what like that so he was
saying that this is one of his lovers I
kind of I agree with you guys him it
looked like him maybe his lover was a
man that night yeah maybe maybe he
doesn't love himself or me yeah the day
before he was posting about this woman
like one of these western women which I
believe was this girl he posted it like
her he posted about her saying how like
he saw her on the side of the road and
he was on his motorcycle and he just had
to like stop and turn around and go talk
to her and then he when you went up to
her he was telling her like you know
like you're you're you're so beautiful
that I just had to stop what I was doing
he would come back and talk to you and
bubble of like just sweet talking her
and then eventually he convinced her to
go to the his cave and that they've just
started talking
they got raped no no he he explains it
yeah yeah so I read this too and he's
pretty suave dude like he's pretty bold
I think like you just he's just
straight-up with how he communicates and
what he wants and he's also like yo I'm
not a creep but we can hang out and like
he was like up straight like there's
like verbatim you interrupted me I was
riding my motorbike home but because of
your beauty I had to turn around I
needed to talk to you and find out if
your beauty on the inside as well in
Thailand the inside is a [ __ ] yeah but
then the ends of things like the rest of
the story huh I get it it's like I come
on it's like it's kind of creepy I'm
like a strange guy in a strange land but
you know I assure you like I'm not for
that or whatever like you he uses the
situation like he doesn't come off as a
oh so he's upfront about his intentions
that they know ya know cuz he was like
if I were in your shoes I wouldn't blame
you if you don't want to come with me
but I'm coming like or I'm taking you is
really close nearby and like you
couldn't yell if you're not comfortable
whatever you can leave and like he's
just like he made her feel comfortable
to the point where she went back to this
keep my house have no dog I have a cave
and she was like daggers for me not were
you saying how you kept trying to kiss
her she kept saying no and like how
he'll like joke around be like okay I'll
try in like five minutes and then he'll
try again she'll be like no and like
nothing happened between them and he was
just saying like this whole thing on his
Facebook post so then the next day is
when he uploaded that photo of that
woman laying down but it was another
woman it was a different woman yeah he
was like a different lover of mine yo
bro I still a [ __ ] left and right we
get the same puss-puss he has a trumpet
it looks dirty as [ __ ] yeah that looks
kind of cool that's what that's pretty
dope though here's that I even have in
my backyard back at home you know
where does he wash his sheets I thought
the cops do skunk with human with human
liquids that's like that just goes to
show that women are very accepting yeah
I need it I need to get a cab and I
think just people some people are very
exactly I live in a [ __ ] cave masks
winos dude [ __ ] man as Steve was saying
musk why don't you piss on yourself and
it's like oh my god that is I joined the
cave too
I'd [ __ ] let them [ __ ] me [ __ ] me for
that view I I was like if I saw that
majestic ass please I'll be like you
just gotta take a picture that place and
keep it on a cellphone excuse me to
interrupt you but I just want to do more
Tyana cervix so what's the I guess like
the the big thing that's going on with
them right now cuz I did read this I was
like oh cool that's pretty awesome well
he's just going viral because of the his
Facebook page how are you seducing women
how it's Western women the fact that he
lives in a cave is that is that big or
something I guess in Thailand maybe what
do you mean big oh the one time [ __ ]
why people get fetish sighs shut the
[ __ ] up dude like help come on dude
okay then why people fair-sized asian
black people mixing people all the
[ __ ] time so it happened one way or
the other
whatever [ __ ] it is it because I don't
know I guess to me I thought we kind of
we're in a different era now and then
like it's like wow a non-white man
dating a lot of white girls it's like is
that a big deal I think the biggest well
maybe you could explain it cuz you're
you're happy about it to me I'm just
like I thought that's normal in cave and
he's such a playboy is the big like oh
my god like what but it's it's it's more
like like homeless man bangs a lot of
girls looks like it does it's a rich dog
in Aisle 4 stockade that shit's got a
lot it feels like I'm in a different
whole entire universe like when you walk
into that realm it's like yo man this is
like [ __ ] Thai Willy Wonka what is
there a post this place on Airbnb or
something I hope not imagine the [ __ ]
blue light [ __ ] you're gonna [ __ ] I
would go in there the whole room would
just glow dude like not a single spot
wooden club as I always clean it's like
no it's actually glowing everywhere
dark spot that's the one spot that
wasn't just it's like that [ __ ] you
know when the waves crash and there's a
bacteria thing yeah yeah the plankton or
whatever and it sparkles that's like
it's come spray oh god that's a healthy
spray
he has about 94 thousand followers oh I
thought you're gonna say like lovers
damn he had 94 thousand lovers gross I'm
surprised he doesn't have the STB we
don't load it oh you know all these
ladies they don't know that no even on
Dana that's the chakras I mean he's been
doing well he's 48 he's been doing this
for a while he was smashed and that's a
nice ass bike to like that's not cheap I
don't know what he does for money or
anything these ladies give him some
money dude so you just the ultimate
playboy they might they might give them
money what's it like to just seduce
women like that at your well dude you
gotta write a book bro
some of these guys they keep asking like
how you get wait a minute [ __ ] no
don't ask me how do you
or maybe just you specifically because
it's like they can't wrap their brain
I did a video on this I was like am I
not gargoyle like what the [ __ ] they're
like yo how do you get a cute girl like
Mary oh wait what is it what what do you
trying to say man like what oh what the
[ __ ] am i doing like wow like I get
Barbra like how did you do it they would
say some [ __ ] and I got so mad like I
literally respond I was like hold on a
second
do you think I'm you I am NOT you you're
way worse than me with it so they really
what if they think they're better than
you and they're like if David could do
it but I can't do it I don't know why
but literally I did a video on it and so
like I asked the dude I was like yo what
can I I won't put a picture of your face
but like are you in for some like brutal
honesty he's like go ahead man go ahead
I love your videos but the dude was I'm
it's like come on bro like you dress he
came off as if like hey you're a loser
but you could do it how come I don't
think that's what he meant but it's kind
of funny and he knows like I do
I just go back and forth with my
followers anyways and I used it but it
was kind of funny because he was like oh
just give me your brutal onset it's okay
if you like trash me I'm not cool
whatever but the dude was like I was
like come on man like you got that
greasy asian hair guy thing going on you
don't trust me you know and you keep
asking for like a cute girl it's like
bro you're not even a cute guy so like
your standard of what you wanted women
should also reflect on what you expect
out of yourself you can't just go out
there and say like I want a cute girl
when you don't do the same for yourself
that's not fair to them oh yeah that
reminds me of all those like Asian guys
that say like oh yeah like non-asian
girls don't like us and [ __ ] and I'm
like well majority of the people that
say that don't dress well they don't
keep good hot they don't they don't
clean themselves up they don't you know
do their hair and it's and then they're
blaming like Oh
aegeon guys yeah it's like no it's not
it's pretty much you yeah
[Music]
[Music]